well riot finally came through after
begging them to do something for months
and months they gave chamber a real nerf
but if everything was 100 fixed i
wouldn't be here talking to you right
now because the question still remains
is it enough
[Music]
before i get into it i just want to
remind you guys to like the video
subscribe to the channel and turn on
notifications so that you don't miss the
next time i complain about chamber which
will probably happen again alright so in
case you've been living under a rock
chamber has been a bit of a problem in
valor ever since his release he's taken
every sentinel and jet player's jaws by
fulfilling both of their roles better
than any other agent he's the most
oppressive character in the game back in
may riot tested out an initial chamber
nerf that took away one of his
trademarks but nobody had any
clue why they were doing it barely
anyone agreed with the change but riot
went ahead with it anyways and honestly
it didn't really change much especially
in pro play looking like a very strong
ascent right now
winning their jewels getting the reads
all pieces of that puzzle are just
working out like the biggest piece
you might as well form an entire picture
with a puzzle piece of c ned
you don't need anybody else he completes
a whole team at masters copenhagen
chamber players continued to dominate
the top four teams all had cracked
chambers who'd be expected to pop off
this agent's strong suit has always been
in the first kill department and that
trend continued in copenhagen to help
paint the picture a little better here
are some copenhagen stats from valerian
analyst willminder on the left we have
the top 10 players in first blood
percentage on the attacking side and on
the right we have the top 10 players for
the defending side you might have
noticed that there's a lot of chamber on
those lists my boy ominous also noted
that jet had her lowest ever pick raid
at an international event throughout
masters copenhagen if chamber killed jed
upon his release then this felt like he
was really burying her but why does this
matter most of us hated jet dominating
the meta too right well the problem
aside from just agent diversity is that
at least for me chamber's just boring to
watch seeing someone hold an angle get a
pic then tp out without getting traded
is just frustrating to watch there's
very little counter play which makes it
predictable for spectators and the issue
was that chamber could do this up to
seven times per round if the round went
the distance so that's why riot began
testing additional nerfs on the pbe a
couple weeks ago the proposed changes
nerfed his rendezvous cooldowns the slow
duration on his alt and trademark the
cost of his alt and the cost of his
headhunter and i think everyone was
happy to finally see a proper nerf in
the works some people even thought that
these changes would help prevent him
from being an essential pick on certain
maps ultimate costs one more point
that's good
bullet cost increase 150 that's good i
think that now chamber clearly has you
know downsides there's clearly
weaknesses to chamber now
that you know might make you want to
pick something else particularly on
certain maps and i think that that is
the big thing right he might be
irrelevant for like a few maps but he
definitely won't be relevant for like
all the maps anymore um just because uh
that is it's mainly the tp radius nerf
that really kind of like uh hurt him the
most the tp radius is the hardest
hitting nerf not to mention like all the
other small ones but the tp radius
really kind of like in the midst angles
you can play fast forward to this week
and these nerfs are now live and the
community at large has been celebrating
the death of chamber but i gotta ask is
he really dead i've been testing out
these nerfs the past couple of weeks and
it's definitely a nerf but it's honestly
not as bad as i expected it to be you
need to be aware of the rendezvous
radius change when taking fights but it
didn't take me long to get used to
because the distance between both
anchors wasn't nerfed i'm still able to
place them in all the same spots that i
used to obviously you won't be
purchasing as many headhunter shots as
you used to but since the cost of his
trademark wasn't nerfed you still only
need 4 100 credits to get a proper buy
with chamber and what i mean by that is
full armor a rifle and his trademark if
you don't count headhunter he still has
one of the cheapest kits so although i
think it's a step in the right direction
i would honestly consider nerfing the
cost of his trademark in the future as
for the slow duration on his trademark i
think lowering it to six seconds is good
that lasted an eternity before so i
think it's completely fair lastly we
have results toruta forest now costs an
extra alt point but i didn't really
notice it that much if you're playing
chamber and you're doing what you're
supposed to which is getting kills then
you'll likely still get your outback
pretty fast and it's still busted in the
right hands so like i said i think these
nerfs are definitely a step in the right
direction but chambers still pretty
strong and definitely viable in my eyes
some people still think he's broken too
it did not do anything to chamber i was
playing yesterday chambers the same
agent he's just i don't know what i
don't know what they need to do
but he's still he's still chamber he is
still as strong he's still
he's still crazy ideally we all want
agents who do well in certain situations
at certain times and on certain maps and
this should help him become more like
that rather than an essential pick
across the board although a lot of us
would have loved to see him get nerfed
to the ground i think we'll continue to
see chamber in matchmaking and pro play
for now so you'll definitely still find
me and still locking him for now
but like i hate him so much because i
know he's so good and i like am forced
to still play him
that's that's what i wanted it to sound
like though
stupid
dumb ass brain dead agent
should i do it like that or should i do
it a bit softer